the same modern history last hundred
years to fight literally for your life
who would it be
oh God you know I'm a big Ali fan he was
so iconic and he changed so many things
uh in the world and culture and and uh
you know as far as racism and so many
different things go Ali was such a
massive figure in life you know not just
boxing
um
was he the greatest ever out of one of
the greatest humans ever that's a fact
but that's not the question as far as
they did lose three times I know Jon
Jones who's in the UFC still has never
been beat this guy has beat everybody
and when you talk about real fighting
you know when you talk about who the
baddest man on the planet is when you
talk about that the real
definition of what that means you throw
two guys in a room and who comes out
yeah okay that's the baddest man on the
planet